I got to see that ring girl Anna camp  flashes that huge rock of hers the  unbreakable kimmy schmitt star hit  wednesday night's premiere with her  pitch-perfect co-star and real-life love  skylar astin the couple is busy planning  their upcoming I Do's so how is the  wedding planning going how far in the  stage are you we're like deep like agree  on everything it's been really fun it's  been really seamless and like I say it  she says things right before I'm about  to say them it's really like it's we're  planning a really fun party you're so  excited please tell me that we're gonna  have a pitch-perfect reunion at that  wedding the two got engaged this past  January in Hawaii and yes it's a  squirrel Mantic as it sounds it was just  a beautiful little lookout area and I  said some things she said them some  things we both cried I asked the  infamous question she said guests thank  God